alors que le nombre de contaminations ne
cesse de battre des records le
gouvernement annonce qu'un
assouplissement les détails dans un
instant
[Musique]
l' attaque nocturne avait fait craindre
une guerre entre téhéran et washington
qu'il y a deux ans était assassiné par
les états unis le général iranien qassem
suleimani
anniversaire commémoré à bagdad par les
partisans de factions armées irakiennes
il appelle au retrait des soldats
américains d'irak
[Musique]
seize mois après l'explosion qui a
ravagé le port de la capitale libanaise
l'anc est stable aucune responsabilité
établie à ce jour dans ce drame qui a
coûté la vie à plus de 215 personnes le
juge contraint cette semaine de
suspendre une nouvelle fois ses
investigations en cause nous le verrons
la multiplication des recours
judiciaires
[Musique]
et
bonsoir a tous très bon début d'année et
bienvenus si vous nous rejoignez sur rt
france un début d'année marqué par de
nouvelles mesures anti qu'ovide dans le
viseur des autorités le variant omicron
qui se propage à vitesse grand v il sera
l'objet d'une réunion demain à matignon
frantz jean castex et une dizaine de
ministres ils feront le point sur son
impact au moment où le nombre de
contaminations explose pour tenter
d'enrayer sa propagation malades positif
au co vides sont isolés comme les cas
contacts au risque de la paralysie
économique c'est donc pour l'éviter que
le gouvernement a décidé de revoir les
délais d'isolement c'est l'une des
nouvelles mesures qui entrent en vigueur
demain on fait le point en images
le port du masque devient obligatoire
pour les enfants à partir de 6 ans dans
les transports collectifs
contrairement à d'autres pays le masque
ffp2 n'est cependant pas imposé je ne
souhaite pas en faire l'alpha et l'oméga
de la lutte contre le virus il ne suffit
pas d'emporter rhin pour ne pas être
contaminé et le masque chirurgical offre
un niveau de protection très élevé
certains pays imposent le port du masque
ffp2 dans les transports s'il estime que
la situation le justifie le haut conseil
de santé publique peut proposer de faire
évoluer la doctrine sur ce point à tout
moment nous suivrons alors ses
préconisations mais pour le moment ce
n'est pas le cas alors que le port du
masque était déjà obligatoire pour les
enfants à partir de 11 ans ce changement
prend effet au moment où la restauration
dans les transports devient interdite le
masque ne pourra pas être retirés dans
les trains mais aussi dans les avions
lors des vols intérieurs exception faite
pour l'eurostar et le thalys ou encore
pour les restaurants des bateaux des
restrictions surprenante qui n'ont pas
manqué de faire réagir l'opposition en
multipliant les mesures punitives qui
n'ont aucun sens le gouvernement s'agite
au lieu d'agir comment accepter des
mesures aussi ridicule que
l'interdiction de danser boire debout
manger dans un train ou l'obligation de
porter un masque dans la rue
pas de café debout pas de pop corn
cinéma pas de chips dans le train
la nouvelle politique sanitaire du
gouvernement est encore plus folle que
l'ancien autre mesure qui entre en
vigueur ce lundi les restaurants ne
pourront accueillir du public que s'ils
ont des places assises pour toute la
clientèle avec obligation du port du
masque pour se déplacer notamment pour
les enfants à partir de 6 ans pour
favoriser un retour à la normale le
gouvernement a décidé d'alléger les
règles d'isolement pour les personnes
positives au coville 19 ayant un schéma
vaccinal complet ces dernières devront
désormais s'isoler 7 jours et 7
quarantaine pourra être levée au bout de
cinq jours si la personne fait un test
pcr qui se révèle négatif à condition de
ne plus avoir de signes cliniques
d'infection depuis 48 heures les
personnes ayant un schéma vaccinal à
jour qui auront été au contact d'une
personne positive aux colis 19 n'auront
plus à s'isoler mais devront se montrer
prudente et privilégier le télétravail
dans la mesure du possible pour les
personnes n'ayant pas un schéma vaccinal
complet et qui seraient testées
positives au qu'ovide la durée
d'isolement sera de 10 jours et pourra
être levée à 7 sous les mêmes conditions
les cas contacts non vaccinés ou dont le
schéma vaccinal ne serait pas à jour
devront s'isoler au moins sept jours un
assouplissement des mesures qui se
justifie par une incubation moins long
du variant mikron et à la nécessité de
maintenir la vie socio économique
malgré l'évolution de la pandémie
de nouvelles mesures cohérentes estime
philippe froguel et les chercheurs
généticien
je pense que ces mesures sont logiques
mikron arrivant trop chaud donc une
incubation plus courte que les varier
vos précédents très atténué chez les
personnes me sens complètement vaccinés
a soutenu avec trois doses et pour
repartir plus rapidement ce qui re en
plus des raisons économiques pourraient
justifier effectivement des mesures
d'isolement a allégé par rapport à ce
qu'on a fait jusqu'à présent là la
question c'est est ce que à partir des
enfants on va voir les personnes âgées
rappelons quand même qu'en france il ya
cinq millions de personnes qui sont pas
vaccinés et beaucoup de gens âgés qui
ont pas eu la troisième dose est ce que
c'est les enfants vont passer la maladie
des gens qui vont faire une forme sévère
parce qu'ils n'auront pas de schéma
vaccinal complet ça c'est une question
qu'on peut se poser en guadeloupe
situation très préoccupante en quatre
jours le nombre de nouveaux cas a été
multiplié par quatre en tôt 13 au dessus
du seuil dallaire s'inquiètent les
autorités les 10-19 ans et les ventes 39
ans représente 60 cents pour cent de ces
nouveaux cas et la vaccination avance
lentement sur l'île avec moins de 47 %
des plus de 18 ans qui ont reçu une
première dose écoutez la réaction d'
anthony était le maire secrétaire
général du conseil représentatif des
français d'outre-mer
la situation sanitaire en guadeloupe est
en effet critique mais elle n'est pas
critique uniquement du fait de la non
vaccination elle et elle est
multifactoriel c'est à dire que il faut
déjà prendre en compte l'arrivée massive
de visiteurs dans deal qui sont eux
aussi porteur du virus
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
restrictions et les contrôles sanitaires
qui ont été augmentés après
la vaccination en soi n'est pas une
solution
unique puisque les mesures barrières
peuvent être aussi des facteurs de
protection dont il faut user aujourd'hui
il faut plutôt participer à une grande
campagne de conviction plutôt qu'à une
campagne de répression une crise
sanitaire à l'origine parfois de
violence à l'encontre des élus chemin
sulte menaces de mort sur les réseaux
sociaux jusqu'au domicile vandalisé dans
une tribune publiée dans le journal du
dimanche ce matin la députée ch la
république en marche on en berger tire
la sonnette d'alarmé réclament une prise
de conscience collective
aurore bergé récemment ciblé dans un
tweet qui la compare aux femmes tondues
pour collaboration
après la seconde guerre mondiale
j'appelle au front commun contre la
violence dans le débat public on s'y est
trop habitués la bataille des idées est
devenu un combat de rue il y a une forme
de faiblesse dans la réponse de la
société et de certains responsables
politiques
et la violence dans le débat public
c'est l'objet de notre échange ce soir
avec franck keller porte parole du parti
reconquête et williams martinez pour
internationale de la france insoumise
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur un rt france on si trop
habitués la bataille des idées est
devenu un combat de rue est ce que vous
partagez le constat d'horreur berger il
fouilla martinet
je pense en tout cas que le niveau de
violence la société est quelque chose de
préoccupant
excusez moi j'ai le repos quand je parle
assez d agresser de régler ce souci
selon aurore bergé je laisse site il ya
aujourd'hui un sujet spécifique sur la
crise sanitaire qui est en plus très
imbriqué avec le calendrier de la
présidentielle de 2000 22 et la députée
lrm de déclarer que l'entrée en campagne
d'eric zemmour a ajouté au climat de
tension extrême ce sont ses mots qu'est
ce que vous répondez à cela frank l
heure
je trouve quelque part il faut quand
même savoir à présent de la république
de macron régulièrement
fringants et par ses actions et par
certaines de ses paroles je vous donne
deux exemples qu'un président de la
république il ya ceux qui réussissent
sont rien extrêmement violente
n'en est rien un président de la
république le temple il dit être une
somme ils cherchent un emploi il suffit
de traverser la rue pour être ré
extrêmement violent donc faut pas
s'étonner et les réseaux par exemple les
gens et violent
par exemple on parle il ya ça eric
zemmour infirme déposes défend un
programme est en campagne électorale des
gens qui l'apprécient l'apprécient pas
nordea si chacun doit pouvoir s'exprimer
librement
est ce qu'aujourd'hui chacun peut
s'exprimer librement sans qu'il y ait de
violence à l'encontre d'élus qui ne
partage pas votre point de vue
alors je n'avais pas le sont là depuis
quelques minutes donc voilà je réagi
tout de suite moi je pense que il ya un
problème de violence politique qui est
en train de progresser dans notre
société et c'est quelque chose
d'inquiétant notamment à la proche de
l'élection présidentielle et des mois
qui qui sont devant nous mais là où j'ai
un désaccord avec mme aurore bergé c'est
que je pense que l à une analyse soit
incomplètes soit est ornée de l'endroit
d'où provient la violence politique à
mon avis il ya deux facteurs principaux
aujourd'hui qui font que cette violence
politique augmente le premier facteur
c'est la question de la répression
policière des mouvements sociaux dans
notre pays parce que les mouvements
sociaux c'est une expression
démocratique et quand et là je pense
évidemment à la mobilisation aux des
gilets jaunes quand on a une réponse du
gouvernement à ses mouvements sociaux
qui me réponse par la répression
policière parce que je rappelle ce bilan
c'est 1900 blessés ces quatorze
personnes éborgné ces cinq mains qui ont
été arrachées donc quand on a un
gouvernement qui réponde un problème
politique parce que le mouvement des
gilets jaunes c'est une question
politique par de la répression policière
ça contribue à ce climat de violence
politique qui est exacerbée et puis le
deuxième facteur que là je crois aussi
aurore bergé ne n'analyse pas en tout
cas pas assez c'est que une des sources
de la violence le politique actuellement
ce sont les groupuscules d'extrême
droite et là ça tombe bien j'ai à côté
de moi en tout cas la visioconférence un
représentant du mouvement des règlements
je pense qu'il ya un problème depuis que
eric zemmour qui est rentré en campagne
c'est que eric zemmour des complexes
charrie autour de lui toute une série de
groupuscules qui sont extrêmement
violent je ne prendre qu'un seul exemple
parce qu'il nous concerne directement
nous en tant que militant de la france
est soumise il y a quelques semaines sur
les réseaux sociaux un militant qui
était présent au grand meeting de
villepinte d'eric zemmour qui a diffusé
une vidéo ou avec une arme de guerre il
était en train de simuler l'assassinât
de raquel garrido et alexis corbière qui
sont des débuts de la france a soumises
heureusement depuis on a interpellé le
ministère de l'intérieur ils ont
heureusement depuis cette personne a été
mise en examen mais je crois qu'il ne
faut pas liger ça il y à une source de
la violence qui vient de l'extrême
droite et on a aussi besoin de
caractériser cette violence pour pouvoir
la condamner fermement et espérer que
les mois qui viennent qui sont c'est
encore une fois du débat l'élection
présidentielle se passe sur le terrain
des idées de la confrontation démocrate
démocratique aussi radicale soit elle
moi de par exemple avec eric zemmour je
n'ai rien à coma je pense que c'est un
candidat qui est raciste et d'ailleurs
il a été condamné pour ça il faut que ce
débat reste absolument sur le terrain
des idées de la confrontation des idées
et absolument pas qu'il arrive sur le
terrain de la violence est alors puisque
vous êtes vous évoquiez l'instant le cas
d'eads alexis corbière et de son épouse
raquel garrido le couple a donc porté
plainte à l'excès caen vire qui avait
demandé à eric zemmour de condamner ce
genre de pratiques et d'appeler à la
modération de ses soutiens socafl
candidat à la présidentielle dans un
communiqué je le cite il s'est adressé à
ses responsables vous ne fait partie ni
de mes sympathisants ni de mes militants
et encore moins de mes amis je condamne
par avance tout ce que vous ferez en mon
nom pendant la campagne je ne veux ni de
votre soutien ni de votre aide frank l
air est ce qu'il ya un souci avec
certains militants qui se revendiquent
de votre parti ce que vous vous êtes
aujourd'hui débordé par un certain
mouvement
alors tout d'abord eric zemmour et
reconquête nous ne sommes pas des
mouvements d'extrême droite que les
choses soient très claires on n'a jamais
été et on le sera jamais on est de
droite républicaine eric zemmour a
toujours condamné les violences de tous
bords tous qu'elles viennent et rigard
de tout responsable politique tout
militant politique il a par exemple
comme vous venez de le dire condamné les
violences de ceux qui se réclament de
nous de nos idées mais qui ne sont pas
du tout que nous connaissons pas que
font pas du tout partie des personnes
que nous représentons effectivement il a
fait ce communiqué de presse le 22
décembre 2022 par contre on n'entend pas
les autres candidats on n'entend pas
aller les autres candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ou les autres
responsables politiques
concernant les violences fait par les
antifas violences faites par les antifas
savez c'est mouvement antifa qui se
disent soi disant anti fasciste alors
qu'en fait ce sont des fascistes
d'extrême gauche pourquoi je dis ça
parce qu'ils veulent empêcher un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle par
la violence
par la violence candia l'exemple
essentiel de pouvoir s'exprimer
s'exprimer librement ou que les français
qu'on a pu le voir à marseille puisse
venir l'écouter donc quelque part eric
zemmour condamne toutes les violences
d'où qu'elles viennent d'extrême gauche
d'extrême droite ou d'ailleurs mais ses
autres concurrents ne font pas
malheureusement ne le font pas nous on
est contre les violences qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ces la williams martinez
que vous répondez à l'invitation d'eric
zemmour a dénoncé définitivement les
comptes des antilles faa qui le harcèle
ce sont ces termes je viens de tenir un
propos je disais que la question de la
violence politique était quelque chose
qui n'inquiétait donc sur ce terrain là
je crois que je n'ai pas besoin de
leçons à recevoir mais je crois que si
eric zemmour et son entourage est gêné
sur cette question de la violence de
l'extrême droite si bien parce que il
est touché particulièrement par cette
question parce que il y a un lien étroit
entre ces groupuscules violents et eric
zemmour la vidéo dont je parlais tout à
l'heure avec des simulations
d'assassinât c'était un militant qui
était présent au meeting d'eric zemmour
je vais prendre un autre exemple je vais
pas faire toute la liste parce que ça
prendrait un peu de temps mais justin un
autre groupuscule d'extrême droite qui
s'appelle les vilains fachos
lvf c'est un acronyme qui rappelle la
légion volontaires françaises sont des
français qui pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale ou volontairement rejoint les
rangs de l'armée nazie pour pouvoir
combattre donc là on parle de militants
néonazis et bien ce groupuscule fasciste
il était présent à l'inauguration du
local de campagne d'eric zemmour photos
vidéos à l'appui tout a été mis sur les
réseaux sociaux donc le problème que
vous avez c'est pas un problème de
condamner la violence en général parce
que ça tout le monde le fait le problème
c'est que la violence d'extrême droite
elle vient de vous de l'intérieur de
votre mouvement ce que vous considère
être comme une dynamique politique ce
sont en fait une capacité qu'à eric
zemmour et ça il faut lui reconnaître
que des gens violents et d'extrême
droite dans la société qui menace qui
parfois passe à l'acte dans la dans la
violence les bas viennent à vos meetings
viennent à vos événements de campagne et
ont envie qu eric zemmour arrive au
pouvoir c'est ça votre problème frankel
argelès répondre très clairement je vous
réponds nous ces gens violents d'extrême
droite nous n'en voulons pas si les
personnes effectivement se sont inscrits
au meeting parce que le mythe ring était
ouvert à tout le monde on ne les veut
pas on en a envie
l'extrême droite ce n'est pas nous et
ces gens qui sont jeu nous le disons
clairement nous l'extrême droite on n'en
veut pas nous sommes des gens qui
défendons des valeurs des idées par
contre je vous entend pas beaucoup
réagir sur les antifas sur ces
mouvements d'extrême gauche
effectivement qui se réclament de fou
également et là par contre ça va
manifestement il n'y a pas de réaction
de votre part donc clairement moi je le
retiens mes mouvements je lance moi je
vais les emmener dans une très précieuse
anti spam nous n'appelons pas bah on a
vu des personnes si aussi des personnes
qui étaient avait en photo avec monsieur
mélenchon qui était à marseille par
exemple parmi des antilles fin mais on
va pas rentrer là dedans ça sert à rien
ça sert à rien on condamne les violences
on ne veut pas de gens d'extrême battre
avec nous mais par contre 15,4 l'hôtel
n'apprendre sa soumises accepte
manifestement les antifas où ces gens
violents qui veulent empêcher eric
zemmour de s'exprimer vous condamnez
visiblement chacun de votre côté la
violence faite aux élus la violence dans
le débat public est ce que vous répondez
alors favorablement l'un et l'autre à
l'appel de leur berger un front commun
contre cette violence dans le débat
public
williams martinez à la france insoumise
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à faire ce
front commun aux côtés de la république
en marche aux côtés de reconquête
écoutez moi j'ai j'ai émis des réserves
tout à l'heure en disant que l'analyse
d'oran berger était au mieux incomplète
et parfois erronées parce que je pense
que encore une fois dans la violence
politique il ya cette question de la
répression policière des mouvements
sociaux via cette nécessité de bien
analyser la responsabilité de l'extrême
droite mais tout cela étant dit moi je
pense que c'est extrêmement important
d'avoir un front républicain sur ces
questions-là d'arriver à se mettre
d'accord en disant que la politique ça
doit être dans le débat d'idées ça doit
être dans les manifestations ça doit
être dans les urnes mais à aucun moment
on ne peut accepter que des gens
utilisent la violence pour pouvoir
menacer les autres et d'ailleurs je le
j'en profite parce que l'a récemment
c'est un député la république en marche
patrice hanotaux un député de
seine-saint-denis qui a reçu par
courrier des menaces de mort et des
insultes racistes voilà du coup j'en
profite pour le dire moi je suis
solidaire de ce député parce que même si
politiquement j'ai évidemment pas grand
chose à voir avec lui je considère que
c'est inacceptable qu'un député de la
nation reçoivent des menaces de mort
assiste aujourd'hui dans ce pays
keller comment apaiser le débat public
comment est-ce que compte y participer
votre parti la reconquête est ce que
vous êtes favorable à cette idée de
sanctions ce fonds c'est l'idée d'aurore
aux bergers des sanctions qui seraient
sans doute plus dissuasif que de simples
rappels à l'ordre il ya des lois qui
existent en inde lois qui existent il
faut l'appliquer c'est tout moi je
constate une chose c'est que laurent
berger à une indignation à jeûner à
géométrie variable parce qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est que laurent berger a
fait un tweet qui a choqué beaucoup de
gens un tweet dans lequel elle disait
quelque part que le gouvernement n'avait
pas créé de lits de réanimation parce
que plus il y avait le 10 puis avait
déjà en réanimation ça ça a choqué des
gens et certains non insulter sur les
réseaux sociaux alors bien entendu c'est
pas la bonne méthode pour insulter en
tout à fait d'accord là dessus cependant
on n'a pas beaucoup vu aurore bergé
faire une tribune dans le jdd ou
s'indigner lorsqu'un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle en
l'occurrence eric zemmour s'est fait
agresser physiquement
lors du meeting de villepinte c'est pas
une insulte sur internet c'est pas un
tweet insultant c'est une agression
c'est à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
violent beaucoup plus violent et là il
ya aucune indignation qu'une tribune
aurore bergé pareil c'est la même chose
lorsque le 24 octobre dernier des jeunes
de génération z ont fait un collage
d'affichés à toulouse ils sont fait
agresser par une dizaine de personnes
qui les ont secoué qui les ont insultés
par et il est même perçue avec un
couteau et ces personnes sont reparties
en criant vive macron là j'ai pas vu
beaucoup aurore bergé réagir donc
quelque part qu'il ya des gens dans son
camp qui se font insulter qui sont
menacés ce qui est tout à fait
inacceptable
bien entendu elle réagit quand c'est les
autres camps quels qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs il ya plus de réactions le
dernier mot avec vos williams martinez
ce sera à celui de la fin comment est ce
qu on fait pour avoir un débat un peu
plus serein à quelques mois maintenant
la présidentielle
je crois que d'une certaine façon il
faut accepter que le clivage est la
confrontation soit à l'intérieur du
débat politique parce que quand on
refuse qu'il ya un clivage dans le débat
politique et bah forcément la
confrontation se fait ailleurs à
l'extérieur et par la violence donc à
acceptons cette confrontation là parlons
des programmes par l'ondé et parlons
d'ailleurs je pense que par exemple
emmanuel macron devrait se déclarer le
plus rapidement possible candidat à
l'élection présidentielle pour qu'on
puisse parler de son programme et
montrer à quel point il est dangereux
pour les français ça fera sans doute le
même effet que eric zemmour quand il a
déclaré sa candidature quand son
programme est sorti on a appris que mon
eric zemmour il est pour une retraite à
peut-être 63 64 65 ans eh ben c'est bien
au moins maintenant les français savent
à quoi s'en tenir on va pouvoir mener le
débat démocratique et c'est là dessus
qu'on pourra trancher au moment de la
présidentielle merci à tous les deux
mais sur de rares l'occasion évidemment
de revenir sur le fond des programmes
des uns et des autres merci à vous
williams martinez ou internationales de
la france insoumise merci aussi franck
keller porte parole du parti reconquête
le parti d'eric zemmour
de nouvelles commémorations ce soir en
irak une veillée aux chandelles
organisée à l'aéroport international de
bagdad là où il y a deux ans un drone
américain a tué le général iranien qasem
soleimani l'ordre venait du président
américain de l'époque donald trump en
événements qui a considérablement tendu
un peu plus encore les rapports entre
téhéran et washington
anniversaires commémorer déjà hier dans
la capitale irakienne l'occasion pour
les manifestants d'exiger le retrait des
soldats américains
le récit de rémy ça vaille
les slogans anti-américains résonne
autour des drapeaux brûlés à bagdad ce
samedi plusieurs milliers d'irakiens
sont descendus dans les rues deux ans
après l'assassinât par les états unis du
général iranien qasem soleimani c'est
partisans de factions armées irakiennes
demandent le retrait des troupes
américaines de leur pays c'est
aujourd'hui le deuxième anniversaire du
martyre des leaders de la victoire le
peuple irakien à participer à cette
grande manifestation demandant la sortie
de cette occupation odieux de l'irak
depuis 2003 jusqu'à aujourd'hui
le 3 janvier 2020 l'armée américaine
avait pulvérisé à l'aide d'un drone armé
le véhicule dans lequel se trouvait
qasem soleimani un ordre venu tout droit
de la maison blanche est émis par le
président de l'époque donald trump
durant l' attaque à boumehdi allemands
disent numéro deux du hasch al chabi une
coalition de paramilitaires
majoritairement pro et rend désormais
intégrée à l'état irakien avaient
également péri une offensive que l'iran
impute aussi à l'administration byden l'
attaque terroriste a été orchestrées et
exécutées de manière organisée par le
gouvernement américain de l'époque et
dont la maison blanche est aujourd'hui
responsable
cet assassinat avait fait craindre une
guerre entre washington et téhéran
quelques jours après cet événement
l'iran avait d'ailleurs riposté des
missiles avaient été tirés sur des bases
irakiennes où se trouvaient des soldats
américains des tensions qui n'ont jamais
cessé de grandir ces dernières années
pris pour cible à plusieurs reprises
dans des tirs de roquettes ou des
attaques aux drones piéger les états
unis avaient systématiquement accusé les
factions pro iranienne
ces dernières demandant régulièrement le
retrait des troupes américaines
présentes en irak dans le cadre d'une
coalition internationale anti jihadistes
si nous voulons venger le sang des
martyrs ce sera par l'expulsion de
toutes les forces étrangères pour
arriver à la pleine souveraineté
nationale aujourd'hui 2500 militaires
américains et un millier de soldats de
pays membres de la coalition sont en
poste dans des bases appartenant aux
irakiens
au liban en seize mois après l'explosion
qui a ravagé le port de la capitale
beyrouth s'est tué plus de 215 personnes
l'ont quête piétine les investigations
une nouvelle fois était suspendu
explications estelle farges
tarek guitare est une cible se juge en
charge de l'enquêté sur l'explosion
survenue dans le port de beyrouth le 4
ou 2020 a été contraint une nouvelle
fois de la suspendre le 23 décembre
dernier le juge bittar a été informé
d'un recours présenté par les anciens
ministres ali hassan khalil et ghazi
zeaiter il a donc été contraint à
suspendre l'enquète au total 18 plaintes
ont été déposées à l'encontre du
magistrat
c'est la quatrième fois que l' enquête
et suspendu depuis février 2021 date à
laquelle ce juge a été choisi pour mener
les investigations
il faut dire que tarek guitare entendait
poursuivre pour négligence des
responsables politiques ces derniers
étaient semble-t-il au courant de la
menace constituée par le stockage de
nitrate d'ammonium dans l'entrepôt qui a
explosé ce sont ces mêmes responsables
politiques parmi lesquels figurent
d'anciens ministres et députés et qui
ont donc déposé plainte contre le juge
les appels à remplacer tarek bitar se
sont multipliées dans la classe
politique libanaise ces dernières
semaines certains ont même annoncé qu'il
boycotterait les réunions du cabinet
tant qu'ils ne seraient pas remplacés
noter que le gouvernement ne s'est pas
réuni depuis le 12 octobre dernier et
que le ministère de l'intérieur n'a pas
exécuter les mandats d'arrêt émis par le
juge bitar le corps judiciaire au liban
est malade certains juges ne sont qu'une
caisse de résonance des leaders
politiques qui les ont nommés en février
dernier le fadi sawan avait lui aussi
été écarté de l'enquète début septembre
140 ong ont appelé le conseil des droits
de l'homme de l'onu a diligenté une
enquête internationale indépendante
parce qu'à l'évidence l'enquète
libanaise patine et laisse les familles
des victimes dans le désarroi
679 plaintes ont été déposées devant la
justice au nom des familles des victimes
des blessés et des personnes affectées
par l'explosion lé regard de michel
fayyad il est analyste politique écoutez
je pense que les enquêtes piétinent
parce que tout simplement le juge veut
interroger des personnes qui sont très
hauts placés politiquement vous l'avez
vous les avez cité dans votre reportage
par exemple l'ancien ministre à centrale
lille qui est un très très proche du
président du parlement nabih berri et
mais également d'autres personnalités
comme monsieur machenaud qui est un
ancien ministre de l'intérieur qui lui
de la communauté sunnite contrairement à
monsieur ali hassan khalil qui est de la
communauté chiite
il ya donc des personnalités très
importante qui risquent en fait d'être
incarcéré est arrêté et mis en prison
juges etc etc dont ils ne veulent pas en
fait l'enjeu qui accueille aujourd'hui
lieu au liban c'est de mettre les
responsables politiques en prison pour
des crimes ou des manques de comment
dire de responsabilité qu'ils ont
commises ce que ce soit au port ou
ailleurs il fait la femme fatale d'ici
au prochain point sur l'actu dans une
trentaine de minutes à total
et
[Musique]